welcome i love you please enjoy yourself
welcome everybody welcome welcome welcome
welcome to the tonight show you're here you
matter you're watching thank you i appreciate it
uh well guys this weekend was
president biden's birthday
and uh he's the first president to turn 79 while
in office biden spent his birthday in wilmington
delaware and went to a five o'clock mass man
does this guy know how to party or what i mean
even mike pence has like ever heard of chuck e
cheese so you could tell biden's 79 because when
he blew out his candles everyone started
clapping and the lights went on and off
yeah it was biden's 79th birthday and
he heard from a lot of different people
here check out some of the texts he
got first from vladimir putin he texted
i sent you edible arrangement no need to send
thank you note just speak clearly into pineapple
then barack obama texted happy birthday joe ever
wonder how the hell i'm retired and you're not
next up kim jong-un texted happy birthday
stop i'm sending this via telegram stop
hope you good stop on the ground
even donald trump texted he texted
joe biden as a total and utter failure
wanted to tweet this but can't do it
next up pope francis texted hope
you had a blessed birthday but
if i'm being honest this weekend belongs to adele
respect adele and finally queen
elizabeth texted yo not sure if
you know how to text but just wanted to
holla at my boy to say hpd stay gucci fam
and get this guys uh tiffany's just
revealed its most expensive diamond
it's called the empire diamond
that cost about 30 million dollars
so this holiday season give your loved one the
ultimate christmas experience getting robbed
uh that's right a 30 million dollar
diamond meanwhile all the 20 million
diamonds are now part of tiffany's
cheap bastard collection wow
but if your budget's a little smaller than that
i have good news hungry man and coors light
have teamed up this holiday season to offer
a special hungry beer man meal look at this
it's the meal that says tell me you're recently
single without telling me you're recently single
imagine driving four hours on thursday and when
you get there your grandma starts passing these
out uh well according to a new survey most
parents said that they would happily pay
less for knockoff toys this holiday
season than pay for the originals
and lucky luckily if you're if you're looking
for some knock-off toys there are plenty to
choose from uh for example instead of my
little pony you can get horses on acid
next up instead of rock and sock and
robots they have frontier flight attendants
and finally instead of lego you can get foot
impalers oh that's that's good it's not bad toys
they're they're cheaper they work and finally
this went viral on tick tock it made me laugh
uh while uh hanging christmas lights
and it's like one of those special uh
inflatable santa things the the husband forgot
to zip tie to santa's hand to make it look like
he's waving so he said looks like he's doing
something watch this take a look at this
oh no oh no oh yes it was at the stroke
of midnight when santa finally arrived
if you liked that video you can
see more of it on only santa's
today nominations were announced
for the 64th annual grammy awards
that's right both billy eilish and
her brother phineas were nominated
so i just want to say good luck to their
cousins talking about their jobs at thanksgiving
uh olivia rodrigo's driver's license was nominated
that's how you know it's been a long 2021.
people are thinking that came out this year yeah
the grammys will be on cbs which means the only
nominee that viewers will be familiar with is abba
i love that one
well uh earlier tonight president biden
and the first lady arrived in nantucket
where they'll spend thanksgiving and
that's how bad thanksgiving traffic is
even the president has to leave two days
early good luck to us yeah once biden
left for thanksgiving the secret service
was like human tryptophan is on the move
when biden asked obama if martha's vineyard
would be nice for thanksgiving obama was like
uh you should check out nantucket
i have a feeling uh biden's the only person
who says i once knew a man from nantucket
and then tells then tells an actual story
about that man he was a long shore man
named gary finster
but this is nice before they left for
nantucket first lady joe biden received
the white house christmas tree take a look at this
yeah you know gas prices are out
of control when they're sending
things to the white house via horse and carriage
that was amazing improvisational skills on all
of our part you were doing it yeah come on buddy
come here now
meanwhile trump was uh hiding
in the branches like a trojan
horse waiting to sneak back inside the white house
speaking of trump i saw that
over the weekend at mar-a-lago
he received his honorary ninth degree black belt
in taekwondo this is real take a look hear ya
tying that around trump must have been like tying
a giant red bow around an alexis you know i've
seen those commercials it was the first time they
had to cut a few extra holes in a taekwondo belt
yeah trump is big into martial arts
he's even starring in the new movie
crashing tiger hidden tax returns
uh well this went viral last night the
washington wizards played the charlotte hornets
but all anyone could talk about was wizard
star kyle kuzma's pre-game outfit watch this
wow it looks like a rejected
character from yogabagaba
it looks like someone who said i don't
need to try it on i'll just buy it
meanwhile lenny kravitz's scarf
saw that and was like well hello
hello there
and finally i saw that a very unique christmas
tree display has returned to a mall in canada
some people think it's cute while others
think it's a little creepy here check it out
well now we know what the christmas
episode of squid game will look like
well guys tomorrow is thanksgiving that's right
thanksgiving it's a day that you forget
about all the fighting and division
in the world and just focus on all the
fighting and division in your family
that's right since it's the night before
thanksgiving lots of americans are getting
their antibodies checked to see if they
can fight off aunt rita's mystery casserole
i'm actually hosting thanksgiving uh
my favorite part is guessing which
relative is gonna get the one chair that's
shorter than all the others please pass the
of course uh lots of people will be making
turkey while others will be cooking a turducken
you know a turducken it's a coronary
inside a stroke inside a heart attack
i read that the night before thanksgiving is one
of the biggest drinking nights of the year because
so many people go to their
hometown bars to see old friends
and i think the bars know this i mean take a
look at some of the signs i saw they put outside
this one says come in and check out who
gained a ton of weight since high school
that's not look at this one i said remind
the one that got away why she got away
next up there's remember your math teacher well
he's a bartender now let's see
if we can politely find out why
and finally there's what goes better with turkey
than burping up fireball whiskey there you go
i want to say hi to all my
friends with exchange right now hi
uh hey did you guys see this uh tom brady said
that thanksgiving is the one day of the year
we said screw it and eats just like everyone else
yeah and apparently the meal really takes a toll
on tom brady here he is before thanksgiving
and uh here he is after thanksgiving it's just
you just got to be careful you
know a lot of inflammation yeah
some business news the ceo of ocean spray
said that due to a canned shortage from
supply chain issues people who want cranberry
sauce might have to use fresh cranberries
i'm pretty sure this is the first supply
chain issue where everyone thought good
uh of course thanksgiving isn't just
about food it's all about posting
pictures of your food on social media
uh but there's some important things
to know about posting your thanksgiving
plate so i wrote a tiny song about it
psa thanksgiving food doesn't photograph too
good it just looks like a big old pile of beige
i'm sure your dinner tasted great but that
tan rainbow on your plates not showing up
on no one's for you page mystery scoops of
brown and white gravy filmed by candlelight
ain't the look that home cooking
deserves hashtag dinner hashtag snacky
all looks like you serve wet khakis bowls of
soggy burlap for dessert so psa thanksgiving
food doesn't photograph too good in worst case
scenarios looks gross just take a picture with
your fam or your friends together not of ham
that's why your mom told you to wear nice clothes
well well i read that russia is demanding that by
next year large u.s tech companies like facebook
opens up offices in their country yep facebook
inside russia it's like a fake news turducken
soon putin will be like oh
no the spying is coming from
inside the house uh this is cool though
uh disney just announced that next year
they're introducing their very own hey
disney voice assistant at disneyland
well not to be outdone another amusement park
is rolling out something similar take a look at
this at busch gardens we're proud to introduce
our innovative new voice assistant get all the
information you need by simply saying things like
hey bush gardens what's the weather how the hell
should i know the papers gardens what should
i bring to the park two flasks and a vape pen
and hey busch gardens what should i do next
try not to die busch gardens just
like disney if you drink enough
some movie news uh today house of gucci starring
lady gaga and adam driver finally hit theaters
yep tickets to house of gucci are 18 but if you
go to times square you can find a knockoff for 10.
house of boochie get this actor uh
steve burton was fired from the soap
opera general hospital because
he refused to get vaccinated if
they kept showing him evidence the
vaccine was safe but he had amnesia
wow sorry when he found out he was
fired burton went up to the producer
threw a drink in his face slapped him and
yelled i'll always love you then storm down
hey i heard about a woman
in canada who ordered a toy
for her granddaughter but it turned
out it wasn't very child friendly
look at this and you tanner wanted to buy an
educational toy for her granddaughter and found
this dancing cactus on walmart's website when
it arrived she decided to listen to the songs
one in english spanish and polish it just
happens that i'm polish when i start listening
to this song and i heard the words it's about
taking five grams of cocaine and being alone
her granddaughter was like her
granddaughter was like yeah i'm
really disappointed i won't get
any polish cactus for christmas
has this woman ever heard of the toy store target
go to target can we see that cactus toy again
i think we could have guessed he
was on cocaine don't you think
finally a truck carrying 400 000 worth of
jack daniels overturned on a tennessee highway
spilled whiskey all over the road after it
happened officials didn't know whether to clean
it up or tip over a truck carrying coca-cola i
want to wish everyone a very happy thanksgiving uh
happy thanksgiving man uh i didn't miss
celebrating over zoom but i definitely missed
that mute button uh yeah the holiday is pretty
much over which means right now everyone's back
with their immediate family talking smack about
everyone else on thanksgiving there are always two
kinds of families the one that wakes up early
to run a 5k and the one that stays up late to
reheat all the food they just put away all right
who's hungry let's make some sandwiches come on
i read that more than half of all people said that
they were exercising in the weeks leading up to
thanksgiving you know it might be time to cut back
when we're all training for a meal don't you feel
yeah the first thanksgiving was celebrated 400
years ago in 1621 that's right that was the
that was the first time someone finished
eating then looked at their spouse like
when are they gonna leave
but i hope everyone had a nice thanksgiving
it was a fun day of trying to figure out uh
i hope you had fun
now it was a fun day of trying to figure out
if uncle ralph's vaccinated without actually
asking if he's vaccinated are you doing
uncle rubs he's a band-aid on your shoulder
second shot hurt worse than the first one third
one i'm sorry people took vaccination status very
seriously uh though i thought it was weird to see
a bouncer outside grandma's house id and vax card
you can go see nonna of course a lot of people
like to drink wine on thanksgiving i love how uh
i love how my aunt puts away three glasses and
says boy that turkey really makes you sleepy
yep 63 of people drink wine 19 drink beer
and 10 drink liquor while the other 8
mix all that together and wake up on christmas
they're here in the audience tonight welcome
and in the band wow uh this year as always
the food people feared to cook the most
was the turkey if you take it out too late it's
dry if you take it out too early you got to rub
it down with purell yeah turkeys are always
scary to cook especially if you deep fried
the only thing more dangerous than your
dad saying i'm going to go deep-fried
the turkey is him saying i'm going to
go knock the icicles off the gutters
oh my god
actually i read the tofu turkeys went up
in sales this year it's a little different
instead of people saying white or dark
meat they go gray or slightly grayer me
meanwhile i read that most americans prefer
thanksgiving leftovers to the actual dinner
when asked why they said cause i
get to eat it alone over the sink
that's the best come on i read that air
travel this week was expected to nearly
reach pre-pandemic levels to accommodate all
the extra passengers delta and american added
flights while spirit added another
row of folding chairs to the wings
that's right a lot of people were traveling
for the first time in over a year so things
were a little hectic uh here check out this news
story i saw about it many are traveling for the
first time since 2019. so expect to deal with
all sorts of people at the airport including
the person in the tsa line who has apparently
never taken their shoes off in their life
the people in zone 17 who stand in the way while
everyone else is boarding the person chugging a
gallon of aquafina because they didn't realize it
counted as a liquid people who don't have their
boarding pass handy even though they just spent
half an hour in line being told to have it handy
and of course the hardest thing to
deal with babies that's right yeah
and finally what is thanksgiving
without football am i right
earlier tonight the buffalo bills faced off
against the new orleans saints now as you know
at the end of every season they give out awards
like most valuable player but they also give out
awards during the season i'll show you what i
mean it's time for tonight's show superlative
our first player is from the bills
it's aj klein he was voted most
likely to appear in your driveway
when there's a flash of lightning
next from the bills harrison phillips he was
voted world's strongest cabbage patch kid
next up from the bills is tyler matakevich
he was voted most likely to scream class of
08 forever and then completely missed
the pool he was trying to jump into
oh man
next up from the bills is tommy
doyle he was voted most likely to
rip his peloton off the hinges so we
can ride it around the neighborhood
this bike sucks next up from
the saints is christian ringo
he was voted most likely to have
a rival named jewish mccartney
don't
don't blame me he broke up the team
next up from the bills is matt milano he
was voted most likely to be watched in the
game at thanksgiving dinner then
realize he's supposed to be there
and finally from the saints
is ryan ramcheck he was voted
most likely to eat every food like it's
corn on the cob there you have it you